in the many worlds interpretation of
quantum mechanics every time that you do
a quantum measurement that could have
gone let's say up or down you end up
splitting into two versions of yourself
one who saw the result up and the other
that saw the results down
but why is it that there are two of you
why isn't there just one you who
experiences both of those two worlds
well what it means for you to experience
being in the up world is that you see
evidence for
being in that world so for example your
measurement device might tell you that
it's measured up
everyone else that you speak to says
that they agree they see that it's up
etc so you see evidence that's
consistent with that measurement outcome
on the other hand what it means for you
to be able to see both of those worlds
is to see evidence consistent with both
of them maybe at the same time so your
measurement device you look at it and it
says up and down at the same time or you
find some evidence that the other world
exists what i'm going to show in this
video though is that that won't be
possible you're only going to see
evidence consistent with one of the
universes so for example you do the
measurement and then you see the outcome
up and so then you try and find evidence
for the down world but you won't be able
to your detector will say that it was up
if anyone else saw the measurement they
will agree with you they will all think
that it was up and nothing that you can
do will find any concrete evidence at
all of the down world existing
by the way i'm still on holiday so
yes this is my phone taped to a box
that's balancing on another box
i'm a professional all right so here's
our electron
a bunch of people ask me why is the
electron sad that is this little joke
that i have in my head and um i think
you can figure it out for yourself so we
have this electron and we're going to
measure something called the spin of the
electron the spin is just something that
tells us how the electron is going to
respond to a magnetic field so we're
going to set up this little box
that has a magnetic field it's called a
stan gerlach machine
it's just a non-uniform magnetic field
if our electron was in a state that will
call up
i'm going to write the states like this
then
the electron would kind of travel up
when it experiences this field on the
other hand
if the state of the electron is down
then the electron will go
down
but in quantum mechanics it's possible
for the electron to be in a state up
plus down so that means that it's
somehow doing both
which leads to the weird conclusion that
it should be
going both up
and down
when put in the stone go like machine
like we talked about last time you can
just put some detectors here and if the
electron turns up in the state
up then this will register
up
but if the electron turns up in the
state down then this will register
down
usual quantum mechanics just says that
this machine just collapses the state of
this electron so if the machine sees
that the electron is in state down then
the electron stops being in a
superposition of both of those states
and instead just becomes a down electron
and stays that way
so the many world's description of
what's going on when you do a
measurement is that this detector will
have detected the electron being in both
state up and state down
but why don't we ever see that why is it
that when you know if you go into a lab
yourself and you look at a detector that
was measuring an electron like this you
wouldn't see the detector showing
somehow both up and down you would just
see one to understand this let's go a
bit back to basics so we're actually
going to consider a simpler case to
start off with and that is the case
where actually the electron is
definitely from the start
in the up state
so the electron will certainly go
upwards the detector will certainly
detect it in the upstate
and you with your keem powers of
observation will observe
that the electron
is in the upstate because the detector
is pointing up
how can we quantum mechanically talk
about this situation
well
the electron is in state up
the detector is in state
up
as well
and you
we can talk about your state you are in
the state of having observed up
but what would happen in the other case
where the electron was in fact down
so the state of the electron would be
down
it would go
via the downwards path
and get detected
as down so the detector's state
is down and
you would look at that detector
and say that the electron is down
so your state
is this
so that is the case when there's no
spotting universes or anything like that
so let's say that it's in state up
then it goes up detector measures up and
our person measures up but now the extra
thing that she's going to do
is she's going to
write down
this little note for herself
which says up
so i'm going to put the papers state
into here the same thing pretty much
would have happened if instead of this
being up it was in the down state
and so this person would write down
and here again
the state
in that case would have been this okay
this is going to sound like a really
silly question but what would happen if
this person
looked at the state of her paper in
these two cases
in the case where the electron had been
up
then her paper would say up and in the
case that the electron had been down her
paper would stay down i know that sounds
obvious but i'm just going to labor that
point a little bit more because it's
going to end up being pretty crucial
i'm going to introduce a quantum
mechanical operation called
c c for check if you happen to know the
math of quantum mechanics this is a
unitary matrix but really doesn't matter
what i'm talking about is
this operation is something that is
going to happen to this state and in
this case what it represents
is our person
looking at the piece of paper and
deciding whether it is consistent with
the experience of being in an up world
or consistent with being in the uh down
world so in other words this c operation
is literally just the um the physical
process of her picking up the piece of
paper looking at what's written on it
and then going oh this evidence points
to me being in a down world or an
upworld um that's all it is so that's
the physical process that c represents
so um we're going to apply c onto this
state what happens
all right my drawing is atrocious um but
what this means is this person looks at
her piece of paper and you know in this
case she was in the down world and so
she had written down originally and now
she's looking at the piece of paper and
she declares oh i'm in a down world so
that's like her experiencing this piece
of evidence and
i'm gonna write that state of that as
this little thing here this is her
having the
experience of being in a down world so
like which so far isn't weird because
she absolutely is like with a 100
probability the electron is down in this
case and so you know it makes sense for
her to have the experience of being in
the down world when she like looks for
evidence by the way i have a piece of
paper here but it really didn't need to
be paper like instead of it being paper
she could have just gone and like told
one of her colleagues and said hey um
just so you know i did a measurement it
came out as down can you remember that
for me i'm gonna ask you later and so
then c would be the operation of her
going back later and asking her friend
do you remember what that result was and
then saying exactly what it was um and
her going okay well like that evidence
is consistent with me being in a down
world okay so so far nothing weird about
this it might just seem a little bit
strange that i'm really laboring this
and writing it all in this funny
notation you'll see why in a second
because now we're going to use this
property of quantum mechanics that's
pretty important that's called linearity
this is the only bit of maths that you
really really need to know to understand
what happens in the many worlds
interpretation so um kind of generally
this is what it means
if you have a superposition so a
superposition of one state and another
state and you know individually what
would happen to this state and you know
individually what would happen to that
state then when you add them together
the result of the future state is going
to be as if you let this one evolve and
you let this one evolve and then you add
them together so maybe let me make that
a little bit more concrete the weird
thing happens when you consider what
would happen if you had started off in
the superposition state
we want to find out what would have
happened if you applied c to that
combination state in quantum mechanics
linearity means that when you have a
combination state like this you can
figure out what happens to it when it
evolves under an operator like c by
figuring out what happens to one of its
parts so this part
and when c acts on it and then figuring
out what happens to the other part when
c acts on it which is here
this equation looks pretty innocuous but
this is actually the crux of it because
look at what it's saying
it's saying that if you want to know
what happens to that combination state
which is the state where you put in both
of those things
and now you end up splitting into both
universes then you can first look at
what happens with just the state where
it was all up and just the state where
it's all down
what happens to this person when she
looks at her piece of paper we know that
according to the many worlds
interpretation and the maths that we did
just before that there are two versions
of herself we're trying to show that um
she won't be able to find any evidence
of the other version of herself so if
she were to find herself in the up
universe that there is no way that she
could verify that the down universe even
exists
and we're going to see exactly why that
is now one way that she might try and
find evidence of the other world is by
looking at that piece of paper because
she knows that if there really is
another world with another version of
herself then that version of herself has
written the other result on the piece of
paper in other words there are two
versions of this piece of paper one that
says up and one that says down is she
going to see the one consistent with the
universe that she's in or is she going
to be able to experience the other
universe
let's see
all right so this plus this
[Music]
we know that goes
to those two parts so it's this part and
this part
all right so here is that horrible state
it's just this
which is that state
uh plus
this which is that
so just put them into this equation here
um but what does this mean
does she have the experience of seeing
both pieces of paper or not and does she
convince herself that she's in both
worlds or not
well you can see that here
her state is
in the state of being utterly convinced
that she's in the
up world here
and in this one
of being utterly convinced that she's in
the down world because all of the
evidence that she's looked at like this
piece of paper
is consistent with one of the world's
only so both versions of herself will
look at that piece of paper and look at
whatever other evidence and only see
evidence for being in one of the worlds
one of them will be convinced that she
is in the upworld for sure and the other
one will be convinced that she's in the
down world for sure and neither of them
will ever be able to see any evidence of
the other world existing
this example isn't proof that you
wouldn't be able to experience any of
the other universes because after all
this is just one attempt that you might
make to try and see um the other
universe and this is the sort of like
most obvious thing you would do which is
just like looking for obvious evidence
of the other world existing our person
here though knows some quantum mechanics
and so she's not just going to do this
obvious experiment instead she's going
to do something a lot more clever and
it's called a interference experiment
so in quantum mechanics whenever you
have a superposition state so in this
case
up plus down is the state of the
electron then it's possible to take that
electron and do an experiment that will
verify that it is in that superposition
state rather than just the state up
or down but you don't know which so it
will verify that it really is in that
superposition state and as a bonus that
experiment won't destroy the state so
we'll leave it in that state how does it
work well you need to measure something
else instead of measuring whether the
electron is up or down which would you
know mess up the state so you don't want
to do that you have to measure something
else in this case it would be measuring
um the left brightness of the electron
so you take another stone garlic machine
but instead of having it in this
orientation you got to turn it over like
this so now the electric field's in this
direction and you'll be measuring
whether it's left or right
and if you do that experiment you'll be
able to verify that the electron is in
the uh up plus down state because it
will go left and it will stay in the
previous state that it was in our person
being clever thinks well even after
doing all of this stuff it might be
possible to go back and collect up that
electron and do that interference
experiment
if that interference experiment shows
that the electron is in a superposition
then that will be the evidence that she
needs that the other world exists
because that would show that the
electron has both an up and a down
component that means both the up and the
downworld do exist in my previous video
i went through the maps of what happens
when she does that experiment but the
result is that actually she doesn't find
any evidence of interference and so in
other words it looks actually as if the
electron is only in the upstate which is
consistent with her only being able to
experience the up universe why is that
it's because the electron isn't in this
simple superposition state anymore
instead it's in this extremely
complicated superposition state where
the electron is entangled with
everything here with the device with
every particle inside of this person's
brain this piece of paper everything and
so this is the state that she needs to
verify is in a
superposition it would be possible to
verify that you are in this crazy
superposition state but it would be
really really difficult so what it would
take is for someone else to come and put
all of this stuff into a box so that
they don't look at it and they don't
observe what state anything is in and
then
they have to do this crazy measurement
this crazily large entangling
measurement that involves everything
here so not just the electron the this
detector all of the particles inside the
detector all the particles inside this
person all the particles inside of this
piece of paper and anything else that's
interacted for example air molecules
that might have uh taken away some
information about the state of this
electron photons anything so whatever
has interacted here you better get all
of those put them into a big box and do
this super huge measurement on them good
news is that if you do it well
uh then the state of this
system stays the same
so you won't have killed the person or
the electron or anything like that
um everything should remain the same but
you will have evidence that this state
is this superposition state and not just
one or the other so you will see
evidence for both worlds
but
um of course it is basically impossible
to be able to do that experiment because
that would require you to have extremely
precise control of every single thing in
this system it's in practice essentially
impossible meanwhile for a person who
finds themselves split in two by one of
these quantum measurements
they will not be able to experience the
other version of themselves no matter
how hard they try because all of the
evidence that they see around them will
be consistent with just one of those
worlds
so this video is a follow-up from my
previous video which is about basically
why i really like the many worlds
interpretation and i think that actually
it's a simplification of quantum
mechanics so if you want to watch that
um you can find it over here somewhere
thank you everyone for your amazing
questions on that video there were so
many good ones that um i think i'm just
going to try and make like a few more
videos that try and cover some of them
if you have any more questions i'd
really appreciate them leave them in the
comments and i'll try and make a video
about them
thanks